what's going on guys this is rob and i
had to make a video blog
after all the positive feedback that
i've gotten from the scarlet witch video
uh it just wouldn't seem right if i
hadn't made a video and said something
you know um i had no idea it was going
to be that popular to be honest with you
guys
you know i posted it on the um reddit
movie subreddit
because i you know i know that there are
people on there that have questions
about marvel comics with captain america
the winter soldier coming out
which is supposed to be amazing
i actually bought tickets to the 3d
showing here in lexington kentucky
and i'm i'm really really psyched to see
it but um
you know i know a lot of people on the
subreddit had questions about not just
that movie
but about upcoming characters in the
marvel cinematic universe about
characters that have been featured in
the marvel cinematic universe
even about characters like bucky barnes
you know was buggy barnes depicted in
the comics
the same way he's depicted in the films
and actually there's some similarities
but in the the beginning of captain
america the first avenger
bucky barnes is not depicted accurately
he's actually a teenager in the comics
when we first see him but nonetheless
um you know i know a lot of people have
a lot of questions and i wanted to post
this video to that subreddit
because i wanted people to know that
there's a place they can go if they have
questions for things like this and i
figured what what better way to do it
than just post a video up
but i was a little hesitant because you
know the movie subreddit
at reddit.com can be a little fickle you
know i mean
for the most part and it's not an
unreasonable request but for the most
part
posts have to stick around movies they
have to revolve around movies otherwise
the purpose of the subreddit is lost
but i thought maybe people might be able
to might be willing to turn a blind eye
they might be willing to
to look a look away and say this is in
the interest
of learning about marvel comics it's for
science
but um the the support has been wildly
overwhelming i mean i was on you know i
was working last night and i was on here
and there on reddit.com replying to
people you know and then giving them
information
or letting them know that i wasn't aware
of something they had posted and you
know that i appreciated them you know
pouring that knowledge onto my head and
um i got up this morning and i said well
let's take a look at
uh you know the youtube channel let's
take a look and see how it's progressing
and i was like
oh my god
like 2600 views and uh
over a hundred some odd subscribers on
my channel is like jeez man people love
this stuff
and it's a very humbling feeling it's
very humbling to know that you're
creating content that people genuinely
enjoy
because this stuff's for you guys i mean
i know all this stuff
i know about the creed i know about the
scrolls and i know about the secret
invasion and the civil war
and all this stuff in marvel comics you
know so i'm here to bring you guys stuff
that you want to see
i'm here to answer questions that you
guys have and keep in mind
there are no stupid questions on this
youtube channel if you're not sure that
something's been asked
ask ask it i mean you know if if you
don't know
or if you want to know more about the
scarlet witch if at the end of the video
you know you had questions like what was
the house of m storyline you know what
other indications were there
that the scarlet witch was going crazy
you know ask
feel free to ask and i'll answer that
question as best i can you know if you
guys watch a video
and the video just wasn't clear enough
you guys are just still
not sure then ask and i'll post comments
you know because i'm here to teach you
guys all the stuff that you want to know
or as much as i know
about marvel comics and and you know
hopefully at the end of all this
you know you guys will be able to sit
down and watch a marvel film and know
what's going on you guys will be able to
sit down and watch an episode of marvel
agents of shield like tahiti
and see coulson staring at an alien in a
tank and say oh my god that's
that's a cree it almost said scroll
that's a cree you know and then you're
like oh wow they're bringing the cree
into the falls you know
and you guys will know what it means
when they say that they want to bring
this marvel into the fold because you
say oh
man you know now we're getting into the
realm of the cree and possibly the
inhumans and and different things like
that so
you know this is a very exciting time
for both marvel comics fans
and casual moviegoers because we're
getting great comic book based films
and people have a lot of questions and
people are very very intrigued about
what's going on
and the purpose of this youtube channel
is to answer the intrigue that you have
is to answer the questions
and the best way that i can so that you
guys can walk away from all this
knowing what's going on and having an
understanding of what it is that's
taking place in marvel comics and the
possibility
of where things are leading to so with
that being said i want to bounce off
here and i will catch you guys later
peace